Justin is a minimalistic state
management library for react offering a
simpler API compared to Redux it aims to
provide ease of use without sacrificing
flexibility and performance in modern
web applications it provides a simple
and intuitive API for managing and
updating application State without the
need for boilerplate code or complex
patterns Niklas will teach you all about
how to use this react State Management
Library hey I'm Nicholas tiemann or
Nicholas zeiman if you prefer names that
are pronounceable in English and I'm so
stoked to be able to use a free code
computer channel to show you this course
about State Management institution in
this course we'll first of all take a
look at why State Management is even
that important for react developers then
we're going to take a look at what makes
Susan special as a statement and lastly
we're going to create a little canvan
board in sushdent and react to show you
what a real world sushnet application
might look like okay so to get started
let's first of all take a look at why
statement was important well let's just
imagine your reactive as a little circle
and in this circle you have two areas
that we can basically split right in the
middle on the one side you got your
markup so basically your HTML and your
Series S all the stuff that the user can
see and on the other side you got your
logic so this will be basically your
state because if you look at what react
is named after it's basically to be
reactive so to react to State updates
and that's basically your main task as
an engineer you need to react to changes
in state so it just makes sense to have
a really robust statement on the
solution that you can rely on because
that's the foundation all your logic is
based on so yeah State Management is
important and that's why you might want
to use sushnet if your state gets too
complex sure Norm react state is awesome
but yeah a statement can really make
things easier alright so let's take a
look at why sushant is unique in that
regard well first of all sushland has
very little boilerplate meaning that you
don't have to write as much code to get
started with sushdent as you would with
something like Redux for example which
is really boilerplate heavy next up it
doesn't rely on a provider
so again this comes down to the
boilerplate but it also means that you
don't need to tap into as much react
logic and you have fewer things you can
forget because in something like a
module which can be used in multiple
apps that would provide their own
providers you might forget you're
providing one app and then have issues
that you could just prevent if you
didn't need one next up it's faster than
context why is that well it uses a
little system that allows you to
specifically select what state you want
to subscribe to we're going to look at
that more closely soon but for now it's
just important that it is faster next up
it uses State merging by default
that means that if you for example had a
state that looked like this a is one and
B is 2 and she wanted to update B then
you wouldn't need to first of all spread
your state and then say b is 7 for
example but in something like sushland
you can just say Okay I want to say p is
7 and then sushnan will do all the
merging for you this is just a really
nice little tiny change that really
improves the developer experience
because you have fewer things you can
forget and you have less noise in your
code which again is really nice the next
awesome thing about it is that it is
extendable by default meaning that you
can use different kinds of middleware
some of which are pre-provided to give
further functionality to your solution
there some of which you can even write
yourself so you can hook into the state
management process to really make
sustained your own which is really cool
and this also hooks into the next thing
which is that it's little opinionate so
it doesn't rely on a specific way of
doing things meaning you can basically
like in react decide how you you want to
interact with us though sure there's a
recommended way but you don't
necessarily need to follow it which
again gives you more options and of
course some error potential but still as
react developer I prefer things to be
less opinionated so that they match up
with my way of working with react better
alright so now let's get to this far
starting context but for that we're
gonna create a little comparison graphic
down here so we got our context and from
this context our component will get
state so like this and now let's say our
component has value a
and value B and some other stuff that
you can get from it well in the case of
context you might want to just get value
a but under the hood you will always
subscribe to all of them so if you just
want value a for example but veg B
changes then your component will still
re-render we are going to get into if we
renters are really on the bed shortly
but it will cause re-render which is
something you might not want if
something like value B changes often
because it's something a user can type
into an input field for example meaning
that every input on the keyboard will
trigger re-render which you might not
want on all that many components so this
might actually be not that good for you
so we'll just make it red
now let's compare this
to two
with a solution store
we can still have multiple values in our
store but our element only subscribes to
those that wants to subscribe to meaning
that if value B changes this component
doesn't rerun it just stays the way that
it is but our rerun is really that bad
well no actually not sure rerunners do
run react so if you have some complex
react logic which should probably have
put into a user Factor use memo but
anyway then that will run again on every
rear window which is not what you want
but again that's what dependency arrays
and custom hooks are for but it of
course still isn't what you want that
all of this logic runs too often so you
might want to prevent some of it again
for fast moving stuff like inputs that's
exactly what you want but for something
that changes really irregularly and
rarely you probably don't need to care
as much about it re-rendering too often
and that is because re-renders don't
change the Dom
at least not necessarily because react
uses a shadow Dom meaning that all your
changes are created on a copy of your
Dom and only if there's a difference
between the shadow Dom and the actual
Dom will there actually be a command to
change the dawn which is a really
expensive part about doing front-end
stuff changing the actual Dom by
changing the shadow Dom is not nearly as
expensive which is why react uses it so
a re-render doesn't hurt your
application nearly as much if it doesn't
change the app which something like a
state value that you don't even use in
your component can't of course do so
don't worry as much there a re-render
won't be as expensive as you think it
will so no it's not like sushant would
be the be-all and all of performance
gains but it does still help if you just
have really fast moving data like an
input field for example where you don't
want everything to re-runner constantly
so I still think that statements are a
really really great thing and yeah let's
take a look at how sushed and handle
State Management by now building the
kanban board alright so to start with
first of all gonna need to open our IDE
in an empty directory and then run npm
create Veet which will basically allow
us to create a little startup project
here we're going to of course choose
react and then JavaScript you can of
course also follow this tutorial in
typescript but some of the typing is
just a little too much for normal
JavaScript developers that have never
looked into typescript and because those
should be able to follow along as well
I'm going to use JavaScript then we can
just run npm install or npmi to get all
the predefined dependencies and then
install one more which is susten using
npm I or npm installed because that's
going to be our state manager for this
project and then we can just run npm run
def which will then allow us to spin up
a development server on Port
5174 and as you can see this is our
development server now but we're of
course going to do some changes to this
default setup first of all in our
app.jsx we are basically going to remove
almost everything so that it basically
only returns an empty div with the class
name app so let's do that real quick
like this and now we should see a blank
slate when we look into our browser
which we do but there also is some
default styling applied that might harm
us in the end so let's just head into
our index.css clear out this root bit
and remove everything else in here and
what we now want to do is actually add a
few default colors I've prepared so
these are CSS custom properties which we
are going to be able to use everywhere
in our project these are just some basic
colors I've prepared for the project to
make it easier for ourselves to style
things and also modify them in the
future if we wanted to now let's just
also head into our app.css and basically
remove everything and just add back the
app clouds in here which is going to
have a background of one of these colors
VAR dash dash Color dash gray and it's
going to have a Min height just so it
fills the whole background and then just
to head back into our index.css we're
also going to change a bit about the
body which is that it should have a
margin of zero and now if you just head
back to our browser we can see
everything is still gray basically
nothing changed but we're now using our
own simplified study and if we wanted to
we could of course also say something
like font family helvetica
which we know is going to see it because
we aren't using any text but anyway okay
so now before we get into any advanced
statement or whatever we first of all
need to create our components so to do
that we're gonna first of all start with
our columns so component layer column
Dot jsx and here we're going to double
export default
function
call
and a column is basically going to be
containing all the tasks or to Do's in a
certain State like planned ongoing or
done we're going to have one prop which
is going to be a state which we're just
going to destructure because it's easier
to read that way especially in
JavaScript where you don't have any type
annotations and for now we're just going
to return a divinium alright so now
let's go into our app and add three
columns in here because we're of course
going to have three states so one column
for each now this one is going to have a
state land the next one
ongoing
and lastly we're gonna have done so now
if we just for testing purposes render a
state in here we should see that we now
have three texts in here so good so far
so now let's just add a class name in
here as well
column and create ourselves a new file
called column Dot CSS which will also
immediately gonna import that so
import
dot slash column dot CSS and now we can
basically add some styling to our column
so first of all it's going to have a
background color of VAR dash dash color
array
dark it's going to have a certain Min
height we'll just go with I don't know
20 RAM and we're going to define a color
of white or hashtag FFF now we just take
a look at this we can see yeah all of
these already look similar to what we'd
expect them to look like but we aren't
defining any width or anything and we
also are missing one attribute on the
app.css which is display flex and
justify content Center we're gonna align
items at the start though just so
everything is nice and pretty and now
we're already kind of getting somewhere
even though the spacing isn't quite as
we'd like it to be and yeah some of the
other stuff isn't perfect as well so now
let's just head back into a column.cs
the width is just going to be 33 because
we have three columns and each column
should take up a lot of space but we
want to give it a Max width as well just
so on really large screens the app isn't
unusable so let's just go with maybe 20.
yeah that looks a lot better already so
now let's just give them a margin 0 on
the top and one ram on the sides just so
they are spaced out a bit maybe with 0.5
frames instead of one
and also give them a border radius so
they'll look a bit nicer
or PX and now we can see we are already
getting somewhere let's just add some
padding of 0.25 Ram maybe and now our
text is also a bit nicer positioned but
0.5 frames should be fine as well all
right so now that we've got our columns
let's get into actually rendering
something inside of them so we want to
create a new component which is going to
be task Dot jsx and it's going to export
defaults
function
task
and a task is only going to get one prop
which is a title
you're going to see how all of the other
stuff is done later when we get to the
State Management now we're just gonna
return a div in here again and that div
is just gonna render the title for now
so
Henry of course also going to give it a
class name so now let's just add
task.css interview imported
call it good stuff
and now we should already be able to
style it so here we're going to create a
task this guy is going to have a
background color of white
also a border radius
just so it looks a bit nicer again of
4px and a Min height of let's say 5
frame but we are currently rendering it
so we aren't seeing it either so let's
head to a column just to get started
we're going to go ahead and put this
into multiple lines put this state build
in a P tag
and render a task in here the title of
which is just going to be to do for me
and now we can see here is our task but
the text is currently white because this
propagates down
so let's just go in here and say color
is of course going to be black and now
here we've got to do let's just add some
padding in here of 4.5 Ram again that's
a lot nicer already and also header
index.css again and apply some styling
to everything box sizing Order Box
which is just going to enable us to have
the padding inside of the element and
not increase it further than its Max
width or whatever so now as you can see
here we've got a to-do's and yeah we're
basically rendering them just fine now
one more thing we might want to do in
here though is actually displaying all
status as well so we currently aren't
getting it using a state manager so for
debugging purposes we're just gonna
Define a constant here times status
equals planned and we're then just gonna
go ahead and make this guy right here a
div that contains our title and then
we're gonna want to display our status
on the bottom right so we're going to
add a rapid div to be able to place it
properly
then there's also going to be an item on
the bottom left so we're just going to
add an empty div in here for that and
then we're just going to render one more
div which is going to have the class
name status for now and it's going to
contain our status
so now let's just take a look at our
site again and we can see yeah it says
plant so now we can head back into our
task let's see this person will make the
task display blacks and align items
space
between
I'm sorry we're of course going to need
to make its Flex Direction
column first
and then make this justify content
so that it's basically nicely spaced out
and then we're going to get our wrapper
real quick and give it a name as well so
class name is button wrapper make it
display Flex as well and justify
abundant
space between just so we're able to
space it out nicely and now if we look
at it again we can see our plant is
already in the right position so now
let's just go in here and stylus that is
a bit as well the font size is a bit too
big in my opinion so let's make it small
and let's give it a background as well
of
VAR dash dash color
Gray
light now this is kind of better at
least but still not ideal so now we can
actually go ahead and first of all give
it some padding here we're just going to
go with 0.25 rim and another border
radius
of 4px again and now this already looks
a lot nicer but we might also want to
change its color depending on what set
it is currently in and for that we're
actually going to add one more Library
by using npmi class names which is
basically a library that simplifies
adding multiple class names to a
component and also rendering them
conditionally so now we can just get
into a task right here
and say the class name of status is not
just status but class name
which takes in status as a first element
and then
our status variable as a second argument
just so we basically got a class name
planned a class name ongoing and a class
name
now we can just Define them in here so
planned
ongoing
and lastly
and here we can now override some stuff
from here for plant we are basically not
going to override anything so we can
just copy this over
for ongoing we're gonna go with color
ongoing
and for done we're just going to go with
color done
now let's try this out
land of course always looks nice
then let's go down here
perfect and ongoing should look nice as
well
and it does okay so now we basically got
our basic styling and markup done so
let's get into actually using sushdent
to manage our state in here so for that
we're going to create a new file
called store.js and in here we're first
of all going to Define a variable called
store which is basically just an arrow
function that takes in a set as a
parameter so basically a state Setter
for the whole store and it's going to
return an object and that object is
basically going to contain everything we
have in our store so for now that's just
going to be a set of tasks and these
tasks are just going to be an array and
we're going to add one sample task just
so we can debug we're going to remove
that at the end so our task is going to
have a title
test task
and a state and that state is for now
just going to be planned and then we can
just say export ons use store
is equal to create
substitution which is going to take in
or store and now this easily we
basically globalized our tasks we of
course can't manipulate them yet but
that's going to come shortly for now
what's important is we can head into our
column and actually get our tasks
automatically so to do that we're going
to go ahead and say const tasks equals
use store
be careful to implement import your own
user and not the one from tuition and
this basically takes in a callback
because normally when you're using
something like use context in react
every change to the whole context would
update any consumer even if it doesn't
consume the element that changed here
you can really selectively go ahead and
say okay from our store I only want to
get
store.tasks so only when the tasks
change will this component rerun which
is really nice and for our case we can
go even further and say tasks.filter
and we only want to get those tasks
where our task dot State equals
a prop state
so basically these tasks will already be
filtered to only contain the tasks that
we need to render okay so there's one
thing we need to be a bit more careful
about here because this filter is
actually a mistake because whenever the
return value of this selector changes
then switched and recalls react to
create a re-render and if we take a look
at it a filter will always create a new
instance of an array even if the content
of the array is the same it will still
create a new array and the new array is
a new value and therefore this component
would re-render so there are multiple
ways of solving this one of which being
we just removed this filter bit and
we've got our tasks here and then we go
const filter
equals
use memo
and then we just go ahead and say tasks
copy your filter from up here and put
that's what we need as a dependency
array which is the tasks and our state
and now we basically have the react
solution for this so use solution as
little as possible and then use
filtering to get your required value but
this can be done even better because we
can actually go ahead
leave this filter as is and then use
another function that switch on provides
which is a comparison function so if you
want your component to only review
render on certain conditions then you
can add an equals function here and
solution actually
gives you one of these functions which
is shallow and to get it you just go
ahead and say import shallow
run search done slash shadow
now you basically have a comparison
function in here that will check if the
content of the array changes and not if
the array changes but if you aren't a
fan of this building function that's
fine as well because maybe you don't
like the name maybe you don't like to
import it every time you can also create
your own function which takes a previous
value and the next value
and then it will return either true or
false depending on if it's equal or not
so what we're going to do is we're going
to first of all go ahead here and check
if the length changed so longest equals
previous dot length bigger next dot
length
if so we take previously length
otherwise we takes next length
so basically we evaluate whichever one
of these two is longer and then we save
that length as a number and now we can
just go over here in for Loops so let I
equal 0 I smaller longest
I plus plus then we first of all need to
check if both of these exist so if not
previous I or not next I then we want to
of course return false because they
can't be equal if one of these arrays is
longer than the other one which
basically check by doing this and then
we can do the next check if these are
unequal to each other
then they of course can't be equal to so
we return false as well and lastly if we
went through this whole array and didn't
run into any situation where we returned
false then we return true and now we
basically have the same comparison
function only if we don't import this
shallow bit right here but that we write
it ourselves be careful with this though
because again this runs whenever
anything in your store updates so if you
make this comparison too complex then it
will of course run very often and might
be a performance issue so switched on
wants to improve your performance but
you can of course go ahead and break it
anyway
and remember only run filter map or
whatever inside of a selector if you use
either shallow or your own comparison
function and if you don't do that then
yeah maybe just stick to a used memo
because the normal react logic will
probably work just as fine as well and
might even be a bit more understandable
for our use case though shallow is
absolutely fine so let's move on with
the course now we can just go ahead add
some code in here
asks.nap
and for each task
we're going to go right ahead and return
the task and the title is of course
going to be
task.title and you might also want to
add a key in here in our case that's
also going to be task.title because we
expect the user to only Define each
title once otherwise our application is
not going to really work properly but if
you wanted to change that then you could
of course always go with uuids or
whatever we aren't really going into
using IDs here yet because that would
just
be too much for this tutorial but if you
wanted to implement them be free to do
it so now let's just check this out
again and we can see we only got one
task that's currently ongoing but it's
not red so let's head into our task
and also use the store again because we
only get the title here not the steps so
const task equals use store again
and here we want our callback again so
store
and here we want store Dot tasks
dot find
that specific task
where task
dot title
is equal
to a title
so basically give me the one tasks that
exists that contains the title I got as
a prop so that it can get all the
additional information I need and now we
can just go ahead and render task.t
title in here and also
ask that status or state instead of the
global status variable which we can now
get rid of
and now if we just look at it we can see
uh we got a mistake okay what is it
let's take a look
we can see state is not defined
in task so this happened in here because
we did defined State here but not task
that's that so let's look again and we
can see our state is red and our task is
at our correct position
so to prove ourselves here we're just
going to go ahead and call this ongoing
now and now it's in the middle and blue
which is exactly what we wanted to so
now we're basically already rendering
the task correctly so let's go ahead and
try to add Sun using a little add button
we can add right here so let's first of
all head to our column and create this
little button so delete we're first of
all going to need a div again to
basically display all of these things
next to each other
and then we're just going to say button
add this is going to have the class name
title wrapper
and then we can just access the button
using the title wrapper so task.css at
column.css sorry
title wrapper is going to be display
Flex
and justify content
space
between
and now we basically got our add button
over here and our ongoing overview but
we of course also want to change the
styling of the button because it doesn't
look all that nice right now so let's do
that as well
and here we're going to use something
really interesting which is all unset
which is basically going to remove all
our default styling from this button so
if we just take a look we can see now we
only got this add bit right here and
then we can manipulate it in any way we
want so I want it to be color black and
background white
then I want to give it a little bit of
padding so 0.5 Ram
and a border radius
of 4px again so now this doesn't look
all that nice because it currently fills
in all the height we've got so to fix
that we're going to go hide
hit content
and now it already has the right height
but it isn't centered it so to fix that
we're just going to go here and say
align
items Center on a title wrapper
and now it already looks kind of nice
so let's just add a little hover effect
in here and in here we're just going to
say background is VAR dash dash color
Gray
light
and now we hover over here we can see
yeah it actually looks kind of nice
let's just add a cursor pointer
and then we've got our basic but
so now let's head into a solution store
and actually allow us to add stuff
so here we're just gonna add something
else to a store which is add task
and add task is going to be a function
that takes in a title and a state
because those are the pieces of
information we need to add a task
and then it's going to run the set
function because we of course want to
manipulate our store
and here we will just take an object
and tell it what we want to manipulate
so I want to manipulate the tasks and
here we now need the current tasks which
we don't currently have so we'll need to
change our set of it to give us the
current state of the store so just like
in a normal use State you can actually
also use a callback to get the current
value
avoid state right here which isn't ideal
because we called this state as well so
let's just call it store and then we can
say we want to
use all the current tasks so
store.tasks we're going to spread them
and then just add one new element using
a title and our state
and now we're basically taking our store
and adding one new element to this array
so let's head back to our column and
allow us to add something to it so for
now we're just gonna test this out by
saying on click and we still need to
import the function so on click it's
just going to be empty
and we can say const add task equals use
store again
we're going to get our store
and say
store dot add task
now we imported the add task function
and here we can just say I want to add a
task the title is going to be a fixed
string for now because we didn't add an
input yet
and the state is going to be the state
we get as a prop for a column
and we're just going to add the state to
the string as well so that it's Unique
because as I said we can't have the same
title twice so for testing purposes this
is absolutely fine so now let's just add
one here we can see this is planned this
is ongoing and this is done and we might
want to add some margin in here for
things to look nice so let's do that
real quick
task
margin
button
0.5 flip
and yeah that looks a lot nicer so now
let's go ahead and allow us to add
custom text in here as well so for
testing purposes we'll just add this
again and say
that we want to allow us to input stuff
so just like normally in react we want a
new state for that text and set text
equals use State and the text is of
course by default empty
and then we're basically just going to
do this using a model that can open
so
open
and set open is of course also going to
be a variable that's initialized as
fault
and we're going to say when we click
this button we're going to open the
model so set open true so now let's just
add this little model as well by adding
a div with a class name equal to modal
and inner model we're just going to add
another div that's actually going to
contain our modal content so class name
model content
and here we'll just add an input
with an on change
that on change is of course going to be
just as normal in react so set text to e
Dot
Target dot value
so that we can actually update our input
and the value is of course going to be
our text and we can make the
self-closing because an input doesn't
have any content and now let's just add
another button in here and that buttons
on click is now going to actually allow
us to do a state update so
yeah we're gonna first of all go ahead
and say
add task
and add task is going to get our text as
a parameter and a state from our props
as another parameter
then we're going to say set text is now
an enter string and we're going to say
set open
false and first of all render it
conditionally
so open and add if we're not open we're
not going to render this otherwise we
will and now let's just go into a column
and say dot modal
is going to be position
absolute it's going to basically be a
little background we're going to render
so that everything is kind of darkened
out and not clickable so background is
rgba completely black but kind of
see-through so 0.3 as an opacity it's
going to have a width of 100 and a
height of 100 percent
and it's going to be positioned on the
top left
let's just check this out real quick now
we did make a mistake similarly which is
that use state is currently not defined
which is fine we can just import it real
quick so import
use state
from react
okay so I did need to edit a card in
here because my terminal crashed for
some reason but let's move on we can now
hit add and we can see yeah we got this
gray area where we can't click through
and we got these two elements so let's
now add a little bit of extra styling
for our model content as well so let's
copy the class name model content
and style that as well so model content
is going to have a background in white
and it's also going to be position
absolute gonna get its Z index of one
just to make sure it's rendered on top
and the padding of one wrap
and then of course it's going to be top
50 left
50 percent
and transform
Translate
minus fifty percent
minus 50 and we can see that now
everything is centered we do have some
graphical issues which I can't really
explain currently to be honest but we
can fix these quite easily by just
giving a bit of extra height or
basically whatever you want So currently
I'm using padding so let's just add a
height of I don't know three RAM and
width of 10 Ram
and now if we just head back you can see
okay 10 Ram is not enough
so let's make a 20 grand
and also say display
Flex
and justify content Center
also make this five Ram in the line item
Center
just so it looks a bit nicer and now we
got this little model right here
you can also add a polar radius to
now let's just add a test text in here
click add
do the same with done Test 2 add and we
can see everything works in the way we'd
expect it to
so now let's also add a way to delete
tasks so first of all we're going to
need to head into our store again
and allow us to actually delete them at
all so
let's just copy this over so that we've
got the basic pattern
and call this delete task for that we're
only going to need the title because
that's basically our ID for this project
if you're using an ID then you would of
course need that and then we can just
say tasks is now
door dot tasks
dot filter and we only want to get those
tasks
that don't have the title
that we entered so we want to filter for
all the tasks where the title is unequal
to our title
and then we're basically deleting them
because we're overwriting the initial
reference for the task
so now we just need a way to delete them
so let's head into a task and fill in
this empty thing we have here so this is
going to be an image
and that image is going to get a trash
icon so I've already repaired it so
let's just put that into the assets
folder and delete this react.svg
and I basically got this from failure
icons if you want it as well but that's
not as important right now what is
important is we can now import it so
import
trash from
dot dot slash
assets slash trash
Dash 2 dot SVG and now we can just add
this as a source for image tag
and also give our image taken on click
event that is gonna throw this thing in
the trash so we're going to need to
import
that's a const
delete
task equals view store
becomes store dot delete task
and now we can just run delete task
with a title for my props
and everything will be just fine or we
could also go with task the title if we
want everything to be a bit more secure
so let's just try this out
we should see our icon in here but we
currently don't because I seem to have
made a mistake which is that I used
trash as a string instead of as a
variable sorry for that
and now if we just reload again we can
see our little trash I can hear and if
you click it our task is gone
we might want to change some stuff about
it like for example the size or whatever
but as it's just image tag it's pretty
simple we can just go with task
image and say height is I don't know 1.5
rep let's try this out real quick
yeah that didn't really do anything so
let's just go with 0.5 Ram
go a bit to the extreme and we can see
yeah that works so let's go with one ram
I think that does look kind of nice
maybe 1.25
and yeah and also add a cursor pointer
and now we can delete tasks in any way
we'd like so we can add tasks we can
delete tasks the only thing we can't
currently do is move them so let's get
into doing that using the drag and drop
API from our browser so let's start with
the easiest bit which is actually making
something draggable because for that you
can just head to a task.jsx and give the
wrapping div the draggable attribute and
we now just head back into our browser
we can see yeah we can already drag and
drop this but it currently doesn't
really look that nice because you don't
really know that it's draggable so let's
just head into the CSS as well four
tasks can say cursor
move
and now you can see yeah that's a good
indicator that something is movable okay
but if we drop it here then nothing
happens here so let's also add a
listener for a drop onto our column
we can just edit on the outmost part of
a column and to get started first of all
we're going to need an on drag over and
this is basically just going to be a
listener for when an element is dragged
over our column which we currently
aren't doing anything yet but one thing
we need to do for our drag and drop to
work properly is say e dot prevent
default because by default the drag and
drop API already does some stuff like
opening files and new tabs and stuff and
it won't react to our events if we don't
prevent this so we're just going to do
that and maybe we'll use the on drag
over later for some more stuff but
what's really important is the on drop
because what on drop does is actually
reacts to something being dropped on
this element so again this is going to
be a function
and that function is for now just going
to console.log
so let's try this out open or inspect
element and our console
and drop something and we can see yeah
it was dropped so now let's head into
our store and actually first of all
persist what element is being dragged
because currently we can visually drag
stuff but we don't persist what is being
dragged so for that we'll just add
dragged task as a new Pro which can be
null or a title
and we're going to need a setup for that
as well so set dragged task is going to
run set
inside of a function that takes in a
title
and it will just say direct task
is equal to that title
so now let's first of all head to our
task to set this
set dragged task equals new store
and store becomes
or dot set direct task and here we can
now say on drag start so when we start
dragging the element
we want to set drag tasks
to task.title
and then we of course want to do the
same thing in here which is set dragged
task to nut because when we drop
something then we of course aren't
dragging anything anymore so we can set
this back to now but we of course need
to import it up here as well so
const setback task equals
angular view store with set drag task
and we also need the direct Arsenal
column to be able to know what we
actually dropped onto our column so drag
to task equals store dot track task
and now in here we're just going to go
ahead and consolid log
the task that was currently dropped onto
our element so let's try this again and
we can see yeah test task was dropped
here so now we can basically Implement
our movement already so move task is
going to be our next function that takes
in the title and a new state
run set
using the existing store again
and then says
I want to return
an object of tasks
and here we'll actually map over each
task store.tasks.net
and then for each task we want to make a
check so if task dot title
equals our title
then we want to create a new task
element otherwise we want to
use the current task so basically we
manipulate the task if the title is the
one we want to move otherwise we just
keep it the way it is
and here we can just say okay our new
task is going to be title and State
and that should already be plenty so now
we can head back into our column import
the move task as well as you can see the
column has a lot of this logic move task
and move task and now in here we can
just say Okay instead of consider
logging the direct task I want to move a
task which is direct task
and I want to set it to the state
that's passed in as a prop to this
column
so let's try this out and as you can see
it works absolutely awesomely
so now we can add tasks delete tasks
move tasks we basically got all the
functionality but it currently doesn't
look all that nice so one thing that
would already improve things a lot is if
we gave an indicator that things can be
dropped in here so for that we can just
say const drop
and set drop
is equal to use State faults so this is
basically now going to be a Boolean that
we're going to use to indicate whether
or not we can drop onto this column so
here we can now use our on drag over
function which we're going to say set
drop to true
and then we're of course going to need
one more which is the on drag leaf
which is basically going to be really
similar in the way that we can basically
copy it over completely
and just say faults in here and now we
just need another indicator in here so
let's just go to the class name over
here and say
last names
our default class name is of course
going to be column again so that's going
to work absolutely awesomely
but we're gonna render one conditionally
using an object and the way this object
works is your key is basically going to
be the class name that's applied so in
our case we're just going to say
our class name is drop
and then the value is going to be the
condition under which this is applied so
in this case our condition is just going
to be drop as well and now if we just
head into our class names for the column
and say dot column dot drop
then we can just give it a little border
dashed White
and maybe we make it for pxy
so let's try this out and we can see
yeah it works but it kind of displaces
everything so we can fix it as well
because the boiler currently makes
things wider which isn't ideal so what
we can do is actually give this boiler
to a column by default but make it
transparent and now if we just change
our border color in here
white then we can see yeah everything is
working in the way we intended to but
our drop is currently not being reset
which is not ideal so we are resetting
it on on drag leave which we saw worked
but an on drop is not also triggering on
drag Leaf so what we need to do is also
setting drop to false inside of our on
drop and now if we move things and drop
them we can see yeah the indicator is
removed and everything still looks
really really nice which is just awesome
so now we basically go to function lab
so we can add some extra stuff here like
I don't know buy bananas
bananas
or whatever add some additional
stuff just so we can see that these
things are also growing dynamically
which they are but one more cool thing
we can do is actually integrate this
into Redux basically so we aren't really
integrating into Redux random
environment but we can actually use the
Redux toolkits using susten which is
kind of cool so let's just download
these real quick so Redux Dev tools
Chrome
and then we can basically debug our
whole statement using Redux so as you
can see I've already installed it but
you could do it just here and yeah we
can now just use these if we went ahead
and imported devtools
middleware
and now we can just go down here and use
these as a middleware basically by
saying create devtools store instead of
just create store
and now if we open this and reload we
can see this is now open and if we
change something or add something
we should see
that there are no changes in here
and we can basically just go through
this and see every change to application
which is really amazing for debugging
but you might not be a fan of this
Anonymous bit so let's fix that as well
because all of these set functions
actually take multiple parameters
so the first one of course is set
next one is a Boolean this Boolean will
tell sushdent whether or not to replace
the whole saw with whatever is in this
object or whether to just manipulate all
the objects that are changed in here so
we just want to change the tasks and not
the direct task or even the set of
functions because that's just wasteful
so we can keep this at false and then
the next one which is really cool is the
label so here we can just copy over this
add task for example
then we've got this label and if we now
just reload and add a task called test
for example and head back to our toolkit
we can see this is now called add task
so you could basically call this
whatever you want and make it easier to
debug your stuff so I think this is
awesome especially that they even went
to the effort to use another library's
Dev tools inside of their own ecosystem
that's just amazing in my opinion but of
course no app would be complete without
the option to also persist our state
which is also something that susten
middleware offers us so let's take a
look at how to persist our store inside
of local storage to do that we'll first
of all head back to the store.js file
and then import the persist middleware
from the slash middleware which we can
also use in our create function right
here as a wrapper around our devtools
for example
and then we'll just need to pass an
options object because this function
will actually not work without certain
options the most important which is the
name because the name will be the key
under which everything is stored in
local storage and in some versions of
220 you might run into issues if you
leave this undefined in others it
matches use the world undefined as a key
which isn't ideal either so for now
we'll just go with the name which is
store so let's try this out
reload real quick move our test task
over and
add another test task that's just called
test reload real quick and we can see
yeah everything is persisted just fine
if we now just take a look at our Dev
tools under application and local search
we can see here's a store and a store
contains a full state with our direct
task and our tasks the function of
course aren't in here because those
aren't required to be persisted anyway
and now that we've of course persisted
this we can also head back into our
store and remove the default task we
added in here
so there are tasks are now empty because
it of course doesn't make sense to have
a default task in an app where you want
to add your own customized task that are
special to you but that shouldn't change
much now because it's persisted anyway
if we move something that will be
persistent as well of course but as I
mentioned in the beginning this is of
course extendable to any degree so you
can even write your own custom wrappers
so if for example we wanted to create a
custom middleware that just locks every
state change then we could do this like
that so const lock equals
config this is just a way to manipulate
the existing Setters and Getters and
stuff this will be a function and that
function
will return another function that has
the default Setter getter and API and
that function will then return as a
config and that config again takes three
parameters the setter a getter and an
API so in here we can now just say our
setup will be overwritten so any arcs we
give to it will be locked and then we'll
just run the default Setter again so
that we don't break anything so we
basically just intercept our setup so
that we can console log something and
then move on with the default logic and
now we just need to pass the default get
and API in here because we don't want to
override those and if you now just try
this out by wrapping this around a
middleware as well
like this
then we should see if we open the
console
that everything we do
is locked now
and what's really cool the initial one
will actually be a Setter where you set
all of your default state so if you
wanted to for example create your own
persist middleware then that would be
possible as well we just need to change
the order of our middlewares here
because we of course need to run log
without this persist bit in there so we
just get rid of that
like this and now we could do something
like const current equals get and then
if not current so if we are in the
initial render where current is not
defined yet then
get state from external Force so here
you could do something like a custom
middleware that would sync to your own
custom service that persists your own
state if you wanted to which might also
be handy for you who knows what this is
supposed to show you is that sushunt is
really extendable and that you can
basically build it to do whatever you
want with it which is really really nice
but yeah logger middleware should be
plenty for now so let's just undo all of
this so we get back to what we had
before
with a girl persist and now we still
have a little example of what a custom
middleware can look like but we also
still persist stuff which is quite nice
but now that you've got your store set
up it might be helpful to also be able
to unit test it to make sure that it
will also work in the future to do that
we're going to use v test and if you
help our libraries the most important of
which being testing Library both for
just Dom and react so that we can use
jsx and all of our react logic and also
the Json Library which will allow us to
actually use jsx as I mentioned before
so now let's just go ahead and npm
install these really quick you can just
do all of this in one line and save
everything as depth because none of this
will be needed inside the production
build and then whenever it's done we'll
move on alright so now that it's done we
need to head in our
vidconf.js and add a little test block
here so this is basically a config for
the test here we Define we want tests we
want to allow overwriting globals and
using globals our environment is going
to be the JS Dom Library we've installed
4 to be able to use jsx once again and
then we also need setup files and in
this case this is going to be dotslurge
setuptests.js so let's just create this
file real quick and then here we
basically just need to set up the
default config for the test so we're
importing expect and after each from v
test we're importing a cleanup function
from testing Library react
we're importing matches from just done
and we're basically importing all of
just Dom as well because this needs to
be imported once for everything to work
properly
and then our expect function from v test
will extend the matches from just done
so it will allow us to check for Dom
manipulation stuff inside of our expect
function and then after each test it
will run a cleanup function from react
to basically clean up all the virtual
Doms and stuff so we don't run into any
memory leaks or whatever which is also
quite handy and now we basically just
need to head into our package Json run
test in here
and say the test executes the v test
library and now if you just went ahead
and run npm run test then we should see
that the test is executed and that it
can't find any tests which is correct so
let's create one we're gonna head into a
Source directory and run store.test.jsx
this is going to need to be called jsx
because we actually need to mount our
custom hook that's created from
stroller.js inside of some component and
to do that we're of course going to need
a jsx component and to make sure that
everything in here now works we can
create a little sample test sample which
takes in a callback
if you already know V tests and this
will seem really familiar to you if not
then that's fine as well and then we can
just say we expect
one
two equal one and now if we run our test
we should see that this is true because
one is of course equal to one and we can
see yeah it passed so everything is
absolutely fine and now we can actually
start with all of our logic and to get a
logic to work we first of all need to
create a test component in which our
hook will be used so function test
component and this test component will
take two props as selector we want to
run in our hook and an effect that will
run whenever the values in our hook
change and then we can just create a
little function here so we first of all
say const
items equals use store so a little
store that we currently can't
automatically import so we'll do it
manually and then in our store we're
just going to run the selector
you're going to return null because we
don't need any return value from this
function right here and then we'll just
run a use effect in here
which will run our effect
with our items
and it will of course run every time
that our items check
and now if we want to see how our items
react to certain events we can just
check what happens inside of this
function we pass in and if what happens
inside the function is what we'd expect
then we of course know that the items
changed according to what we want them
to be like
if you don't understand this yet then
don't worry we'll get into it shortly
alright so we can now get rid of this
example test and create a second one
which is should return default value at
the start this is normally not something
you would need to test but just so you
get used to this we'll test it anyway in
a production build you of course don't
need to check if such does what it's
supposed to be by returning a default
value but in our case this can't hurt
so now we can just add this callback
function again to a test this is
basically just the label we give the
test to make sure we can identify it
later so if the test were to break then
it would give us this label so we know
which test broke and then we can move on
by actually saying we Define our
selector
so our selector equals door
and for the store we want its store
but
tasks so basically we just want our
store to give us the default tasks
and then we also create an effect so
const effect
and our effect is actually going to be a
special function which is VI so
the function from
vtest.fn
and that's what's called a mocked
function so a mocked function is like a
normal function can be executed at
runtime just normally but we can
actually check if it was called and if
so with what values it was called which
is really helpful for testing so what we
can do now is we can go ahead and say we
want to render
from react testing Library our test
component
and then we of course pass our two
functions so our selector is going to be
a selector
and our effect is of course going to be
the effect
and now just to add a really simple test
in here we can say I expect
the effect
to have been called with
and then we can basically Supply it with
what we expected to have been called
with and in this case we just expect it
to have been called with an array and an
empty one because the default value of a
store is of course an empty array if I
change this to whatever else like an
array that contains one then it would
fail and tell us no this has not been
called with an array that's containing a
one it has been called with an empty
array so as you can see our first test
that's actually using our little
component right here is actually working
so what is happening here we use the
selector to get our items in this case
our items are just the tasks then we put
it inside of our effect inside of this
use effect and then we check was this
Effect called with an empty array
because that's the default value of our
tasks if so then everything is
absolutely fine and it is so now let's
get a bit more complex by actually
copying this over first of all
and it should add an item to
the store and re-run the effect so now
we will try to actually add something to
the store instead of our effect and if
that works then we know that the effect
should run again because we of course
changed our store and yeah that should
work so here we'll now go ahead and say
store doesn't just return store the
tasks it returns
store the tasks as tasks and it will
also return
and add task function
add task is store dot add task
and now our fact of course can't run
this way either so we need to give it an
implementation so we can say mock
implementation because we of course
can't make this a normal function
because then we couldn't check for this
function like to have been called with
so by adding a mock implementation we
can still make this function do stuff
without needing to get all fancy about
how to check if it was called or not
so here we can now add a bit of an
implementation which will of course need
our items to be passed and then the
implementation will just go ahead and
say if items dot tasks
that length
equals zero
then we want to add a task so items dot
add task
and our task will have a title of a
and the state of B these don't need to
be valid tasked right now so this is
absolutely fine this way we can
basically go ahead and say if it's the
first time that this function runs
because it will of course run again as
soon as we edit the task then please add
the task otherwise just do nothing
and now we can actually check okay
what has this function record with well
it has of course been called with an
object that contains add task and a task
array but before we do that I'll be fix
this we can just go ahead and say I
expect my effect
to have been called times
and I expect it to have been called two
times the first time when the initial
render happens and then the next time
when I added the task because this will
change the state and the state change
will of course trigger this use effect
in our component up here again
and as you can see this went absolutely
smoothly so now we can of course change
our expect down here as well and say I
expect it to have been called with
expect dot object contain so basically I
expect it to have been called with an
object and that object should at least
contain tasks
and these tasks should
always be an object and that object
contains basically this ready and now if
we check this out we can see it doesn't
quite fit right because I actually
messed up a bit we of course aren't
passing an object to add tasks but we
are passing parameters so a title and a
state as two separate parameters and now
if we run this again then we can see it
passes so I just messed up here a bit
because I forgot what our ad task logic
looked like and because we aren't using
typescript here we don't get proper type
in it for this so if you were to do this
then yeah maybe consider using
typescript even though it might be a bit
more complicated than what I'm showing
you here but as you can see the test now
passes because tasks does contain this
object and everything is fine so let's
just add one more test which is even
more complicated because we now want to
add an item and then we want to actually
delete an item but if we know where to
go ahead and say else if
items.tasks.length is one then we'd of
course run into a loop because we
created a task delete the task create
the task delete task so we need to
somehow persist if we already created
the task and that's actually quite easy
as well we can just say let created task
equal false then we can go ahead and say
okay
if
not create a task then create a task
create a task is true
to basically persist if we already
created the task and if so everything is
absolutely fine
and now we just need this delete task up
here so delete task
will of course be store dot delete task
and now we run into our first problem
because the solution store is actually
not cleaned up after each test so in a
first test we added a task and now on a
second test we add a task as well so
this is what our state looks like in the
first test before anything runs at all
we already have a task then we add
another task and then yeah everything
just breaks down terribly so we need to
fix that and tuition actually offers a
solution for that right in their docs
which is we need to mock some part of
solution so let's take a look at how
that will work to clean up our stuff
here alright so to do that we first
we're going to need a new file which is
underscore underscore MOX underscore
underscore slash
sushdent.js so basically inside of the
MOX folder we want at solutions.js file
and here we're just gonna paste the
default config from the tuition
documentation and we're going to go over
each line to see what it does so first
of all we got two Imports here those
aren't really that important but the
third one is so we are importing an
actual create function using VI import
actual solution so what this means is we
are now mocking logic from two students
so we're basically removing all of the
default solution logic that's exported
from the toolten module and to be able
to still use it we need to now import it
using vi.import actual to get the actual
create function then we need to create a
set of all our stores because whenever a
test runs through we will need to reset
the state of our stores and to be able
to do that we just save them in a set so
if a store exists twice then that's not
a problem the set will get rid of it and
yeah we can use it later to clean up
again which will happen here because
before each test we run store reset
functions for each reset function reset
function and what the reset function
does is actually in here because it just
sets the state to the initial State and
overwrites everything which is
absolutely fine so now let's get back
into this logic ready so as you can see
we are exporting basically an
overwritten create function from
sushnell where we first of all run the
actual create function together store
then we get the initial state of our
store using store.getstate
create or reset function to use it
before each test and then we just return
our store so basically we wrap around
the normal create function from sustant
add our own little extra bit here to be
able to do this before each to clean up
our tests and then we just return the
store so such doesn't even know really
that anything is happening here so now
we can just save this tuition.js file in
here head back to a store
and then on the top of our test file we
just need to run VI dot Mock and we need
to pass solution so basically we want to
mock the library solution and as you can
see now our test is breaking because we
expected it to run twice but it run ran
three times
so now let's change this
and now our test passes again because in
run render it actually was run with this
set of items so here we can't check with
to have been called with but we can use
a really similar logic to this created
task bit here which is let's current
items
and current items can either be
undefined or the return value of our
items ready so we can just say on every
run through effect we want current items
to be set to items
and now when I test down here instead of
checking if the function was called with
anything we just go I expect current
items
to equal
and then I can pass an object here but
because I only want to care about the
tasks I want current items the task to
equal and empty list
so I create a task then the list will of
course change to what happens up here
and then when I delete the task again
then the list will of course be empty in
the end again so by doing this we can
basically make sure okay did the delete
task run through because we know that
add tasks work by the test up here and
if it did then did it actually do what
we intended to and we know that it does
so we now tested add task we test the
delete task and we also tested the
default solution logic which we don't
necessarily need to but anyway this is
basically how you would test your store
which is actually quite important
because if you think about it the store
is the most important part of your app
because if it has any logical problems
then those will just spread through all
of your state logic in all the other
parts of your app which you really don't
want to happen so yeah make sure that
your store is properly tested using this
concept or whatever other concept you
want to use I think this works pretty
fine and yeah I basically showed you a
multitude of ways you can do this using
current items or using object containing
or basically whatever you want I really
like this current items way to be honest
so yeah do care about unit testing when
it comes to something like this and make
sure that everything works properly so
you now have a fully functional solution
based camera board and it's actually
tested as well which is quite nice but
there are four more features that I want
to show you that don't really fit a
camera topic as well but it is still
really cool so let's look into them and
the first one is that actions like this
ad password Here can actually be async
so what you could do here is you could
actually do a fetch request inside of
one of these actions then store this
result inside the store so you don't
need to create your own service class or
whatever to do fetch requests you can
basically just use your store for that
because again if you're fetching
something then you're interacting with
state so it might make sense to put your
fetches into the store as well by making
actions async next up we got another
library that you can use with two
student being Emer so if you just go
ahead and run MP can I immer then we'll
basically get a little library that will
allow us to do statement manipulation a
bit differently in a way that you might
prefer over spread spreads so if we now
just change this add task a bit by going
in here and running produce from immer
then we basically get a callback in here
and in that callback we can do whatever
you want with our state so we can
manipulate it in a normal way like for
example store dot tasks dot push
and then we just push the item we added
before using the spread operator like
this and now we still have a completely
valid store and if we went ahead and
tried this by adding something new like
test 25 for example then we can see that
is still working so you basically get
rid of all of these spread operators
which is quite nice for people who
aren't as used to this kind of syntax
and also for big objects that have a lot
of nesting as well like if you wanted to
manipulate an object like this which
would be really annoying because you
need to spread a then B and then change
C in this case you could just go ahead
and say okay a dot b dot C equals 8 for
example which is a lot nicer to handle
but then again for something simple like
an array this is really nice as well
because a push syntax just has less
noise in the code than spreading the
actual tasks overwriting them and all
that stuff you just have a really clean
setup here and one more really cool
thing we can do is basically react to
State updates without needing any react
so we can basically create our own
little use effect only using the store
and the way that that works is we can
say you store dot subscribe and this
subscribe basically takes in a callback
that takes on new store as the first
parameter and the preview value of a
store as a second parameter and then we
can do something like if new store dot
tasks is unequal to previous store.tasks
so if our task changed in this update to
our state then we want to say you store
dot set State and here we could do
something like tasks in ongoing and we
then want to set tasks in ongoing to the
number of tasks that are currently on
here and to do that we can now just say
new store dot tasks
and then we want to filter for each task
where tasks that state
is equal to ongoing and then we want the
length of this and now we of course need
to add this in our store as well which
I've already done up here and we now
take a look at our app and move
something to ongoing then we can look at
our logger middleware and see task in
ongoing is now two and if we do it again
then we should see the task in ongoing
is now set to 3. so whenever this
updates and tasks in ongoing is going to
change and B the according value that we
need but of course needing to do this if
check every time that the store updates
is a bit annoying so what you can also
do is actually do this with a selector
and for that we will need subscribe with
selector as another middleware that we
can just put around our other
middlewares and now a subscribe will
change a bit because we can now add a
selector to it which will be store and I
only want to act when the tasks change
and now these will of course be the new
tasks and these will be the previous
tasks and now we can say
this if gets removed new tasks dot
filter and that's it and now we try this
out once again and take a look at it we
can see now task in ongoing is 2 and now
task and ongoing should be one so we
basically are only reacting to whatever
our selector says of course the if check
is still done in the background but for
us this is just a little bit less code
that we need to write which is quite
handy and the last thing we want to do
is actually type to this subscribe
pattern as well which is we can actually
store State and refs as well if we don't
want the component to re-render when the
state changes so to do that we're just
going to create a little component right
now that's going to be ref test and ref
test will basically store our tasks in
ref where you don't need to do this
right now because our app doesn't really
have a purpose for that but if you had
something like an input field that's
stored globally and some component
needed to react to it then this would be
a really nice option of doing that and
now we can just say constref equals use
ref for this example we can just return
ref.current and run a use effect which
is going to initialize our subscribe
really soon it's of course not going to
have any dependencies because it doesn't
need to have any and then we can just
say you store
dot subscribe here we first of all now
need a selector because we added the
subscriber selector middleware our
selector is going to be store become
stored up tasks and then our second
function will of course take in these
tasks
and do something with them and in this
case we're just going to go ahead and
say
ref.current is equal to tasks and this
way we basically now have a component
where our ref will always stay up to
date with what our tasks are without the
component actually re-rendering so if
some other state updated then we can use
our tasks but if no other state updated
then we of course also don't need to
re-render because this component doesn't
require that for whatever reason and
yeah we basically now have the tasks
listed in here without causing rear
endless which can be quite nice okay so
you should now have a fully functional
kanban board sure there are some things
to work out like as I mentioned using a
title as an ID isn't really ideal you
might want to change that in your
example to replace it with something
like a uuid or whatever but yeah that's
a challenge that you can work out not me
because that would just be too much for
this course as I mentioned before and
also some really minor things you can
work out is currently if I drop
something outside of these columns it
doesn't reset the direct task which
isn't really a problem because I can't
drop anything onto ongoing on one if I'm
not dragging anymore and as soon as I
start dragging something else drag task
is strange but yeah for debugging
purposes it might be helpful to change
this anyway I'm really grateful for the
free codecam team to allow me to post
this course onto their Channel and I
hope you subscribe to them if you aren't
yet and I also hope that you'll check
out my channel I don't do videos this
long but I do do some really interesting
react stuff at least in my opinion and I
think you should check it out if you're
interested in learning more about react
so I hope you'll have a good day and I
hope you check out my stuff and also the
other stuff on free code camp have a
good day